so I have two calipers or dividers
they're both the same if I set them up
you can see the jump from here we have
the jump from this one to this and
that's the same on this set from here to
here and when I line them up you see
that the second division sort of grows
at the same rate so now I've got this
one over here that turns up then and if
you are following along carefully you
can now actually work out what the
number is but let's just stay with the
dividers for a little bit now if I sort
of widen this out a little bit that's
lined up there and then this middle one
is now lined up with the gap of the
first two but this one is now land up
with these two so I'm going to widen it
a little bit further so that I get out
this one now this middle one is like
that and this last one is the fourth
thing are those two sets of calipers
decide they are sir if I go back to they
are exactly the same so we could try and
do it with one pair but it's hard to
line something up against itself so when
I look at the different possible jumps
from this one to here from here to here
from here to these two from these two to
these two and from these two to the full
thing it's the same ratio every time
it's that a specific ratio is it many
things let's find out so we sort of have
from here to here let's call that one
and then from here to here that's going
to be X this is a mysterious number and
then from here to here that's going to
be x squared because whatever proportion
we took from here to here the same
proportion goes from a little bit now
let's go from here to here and that is
going to be X cubed if you recall this
leap here
fitted on to this here and now we've got
something which is going to give
an equation we can say that X cubed is
equal to X plus 1 and this might be
familiar to people who've seen the
golden ratio which is a very similar
formula but you've got an x squared here
if X plus 1 is X cubed we can just
multiply x + 1 so this is going to be X
to the 4 and now we can look at what
we've got and here I've got my x squared
and here I've got my X cubed when I
combine them together I have sort of x
squared times X plus 1 and by this same
equation we get x squared times X cubed
which is X to the 5 across this whole
thing we get X to the 5 and so this
value of x this polynomial has three
solutions but two of them are complex
numbers so they're clearly not what we
want but this is one point three to five
and it is called the plastic ratio a bit
unfortunate as a name
well it was named before plastic was
named plastic and it's the old meaning
of plastic meaning a sort of flexible or
multi-purpose number and one of the
first people to investigate it Han
Stallone who was actually an architect
and a monk I think he named it the
plastic ratio because he thought this
was the real ultimate system of beauty
that you could use for architecture and
all that stuff and he even designed a
building on the basis of it and so he
was really setting it up in opposition
to the golden ratio the real fact is
that there isn't a single number which
can express all beauty but this number
the plastic ratio has many of
interesting properties like the golden
ratio and so it is quite useful for
architects to you know there's some nice
ideas to use in design so we've got
these calipers but maybe we can look at
a couple of the other things thinking
about the golden ratio one of the things
you can do is I can just take a square
and then a build another square and then
I can put a square onto them here
and then a square here and a square here
and I have 1 1 2 3 5 your classic golden
spiral what would happen if instead of
using squares here we used equilateral
triangles I start with a Mac collateral
triangle put another one on there I get
another one on there but now I've got a
bigger one it's gonna go there bigger
one
again one more over here so now the side
lengths are 1 1 and 1 and then I get
this is going to be 2 this is the same
size so that's 2 this is 2 and 1 so
that's 3 and this is 3 and 1 that that's
so that's 4 this one here is going to be
4 and 1 so that's 5 so we get instead of
the Fibonacci numbers 1 1 2 3 5 we get
what Accord the pad of n numbers which
are 1 1 1 2 2 3 4 5 the next one is
going to be 2 and 5 so that's 7 then
we're going to get 7 and 2 so that will
be 9 similar to the Fibonacci but you
instead of just taking the two previous
ones you skip one so I know I start
let's start with just 1 1 1 Fibonacci
would be 1 1 I'd add these two but I'm
gonna skip this and I'm gonna add these
two together so I get 2 that's the sum
of these 2 now I'm going to skip that 2
and add the 2 ones and that's to skip
that and add these two three skip that
map these 2 4 5 7 9 12 16 the effect of
having the equilateral triangle is you
get that skipping effect because you're
going round three sides you miss out the
side you just put in then you're
connecting things up how does that tie
into the plastic ratio it's a similar
rule back to the the golden ratio how
did we find that the Fibonacci numbers
end up be
the ratio between one the next well the
way you look at it is I replace this
drawing where everything is squares by
one rectangle like cut a square off and
if this is five and then one so now I
have a square this is one and one this
is length one and so this length is five
minus one but because Phi minus one is
equal to 1 over Phi so this rectangle
here is similar to the whole rectangle
as I build up my spiral I get closer and
closer to Phi with this it's a slightly
more complicated set up because I've got
more sides there but if I look at how
the sides come together and I can say if
well if we started with one instead of
doing this addition we said this was X
and then this is x squared this term
here is now going to be one plus X so
this is X cubed but it's also one plus X
we again get X cubed is equal to one
plus X which is familiar from what we
had for the plastic ratio
so I actually have a bit of a challenge
for the numberphile viewers there's
something that I came up with it's just
such a simple thing that I can't believe
it's not out there somewhere and so find
find other references to this sort of
idea I guess we need to come up with a
good Greek letter for the plastic ratio
pi would be be good but that's sort of
taken yeah - sigh the plastic with the
golden ratio I cut off a square in this
case instead of cutting off a whole
square I'm going to cut off a similar
rectangle so that gets me about here now
I'm going to cut off a square and I want
this rectangle here to be the same as
the whole thing this is a similar
rectangle so if the long side is not a
one this is going to be one over then
this length is going to be sy minus one
over so and we want this to be similar
so the length is going to be this thing
divided by size so that's one minus one
over sine squared this is a square so
this length is also sy minus one over so
now I can add these two together and I
get 1 so I have 1 equals sy
- 1 / sy plus 1 minus 1 over sine
squared so now we've got 1 on both sides
so we can cancel those and then we're
going to multiply through by side
Squared's 0 and this again gives us that
same equation so this box if we have the
property that we take off a similar
rectangle we take off a square and we're
left with similar rectangle has the same
proportion that we've been looking at
again we get the same equation
coming out you know that this idea of
the golden ratio is one that's just such
a classic anyone interested in
mathematics and beauty would have at
least seen that but when you've got a
very similar process you take off a
similar rectangle a square and you're
left with a similar rectangle I've found
some small references and occasionally
which people will draw up something but
there doesn't seem to be any systematic
study of these sort of proportion
systems and what what you can play
around with them Gold ratio is famous
people will say it's the most irrational
number what's the plastic ratios claim
to fame it turns up in some of the more
exotic sort of still Asians of polyhedra
it turns up in this wonderful spiral but
I think actually this this divider is
the the real plastic ratio claim to fame
because we had the property if you you
notice that I can choose any two of
these pins and the gap between them will
be the power of one number there is a
version of this you can do with the
golden ratio
but that only has three pins not not
four there's no way to do that with five
pins so if you want a set of dividers
where the jump between any two pins is a
power of the same number then this is
the the best you can do
you
[Music]